Memory is a precious resource. You don't
want to waste it. You want protection for the
virtual machines from one another. But at the
same time if there's an opportunity to share
memory so that the available physical resource can
be maximally utilized you want to be able
to do that. So the question is can
we share memory across virtual machines without affecting
the integrity of these machines? Because protection
is important, but without affecting the protection, can
we actually enhance the utility of the
available physical memory in the hyperviser? And the
answer is yes, think about it. You may have one instance of Linux contained in a
virtual machine, maybe hosted by me. And maybe you have the same Linux hosted in
another virtual machine, virtual machine number two. And in
both of our virtual machines, the memory footprint of the
operating system is exactly the same. And even the
applications that run on it are going to be exactly
the same, in terms of the contents. Because of
the same operating system, it is just that we have
two different instances. And let's say that we have Firefox
running on this VM, and similarly this Firefox running on
this VM. This copy of Linux is going to have a page table, unique for this
particular Firefox instance. Similarly, this instance of Linux
is going to have a piece-table deal structure unique
for this instance of Firefox and if all
things are equal, in terms of versions and so
on, then a particular virtual page of, the
Firefox instance running here and the Firefox instance running
here is going to have the same content, whether we are talking about this VM or
this VM. And so there is an opportunity
to make both of those page table entires to
point to the same machine page. If we
can do that, then we are avoiding duplication. We're
not comprimising safety, but we're avoiding duplication. This
is particularly true for the core pages. The core
pages are immutable. So, the core pages for this Firefox instance and this
Firefox instance could actually share the same
page in physical memory. And if it
does that you're using the resources taht much more effectively in a virtualized
setting. One way of doing the sharing is by a cooperation between the virtual
machines and the hypervisor. In other words the
guest OS has hooks that allows the hypervisor to
mark pages, copy on write, and have the
PPNs point to exactly the same machine page. And
this way if a page is going to be
written into by the operating system, it'll result in
a fault and we can make a copy of the page that is currently being shared across
two different virtual machines. That is one way of doing it. That is, with the
cooperation between the hypervisor, and the virtual machines.
So that we can, with their connivance, share machine pages
across virtual machines, but mark the entries in the individual
page tables as copy on write, meaning that, so long as
they reach here, perfectly fine. The minute any one of these
guys wants to write into a particular page, at that point, you
make a copy of it and make these two instances point
to different machine pages, so that is one way of doing it.